.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Auf Schweizer Feldern
werden jährlich mit viel Aufwand
Hundertausende Tonnen
Früchte und Gemüse angebaut.
Doch fast die Hälfte davon
wird weggeworfen.
Das man sich das leisten kann,
ist äh ...
Dagegen kämpfen wir.
Dass man nicht mehr achtlos sagt:
"Das ist Abfall."
Foodwaste muss nicht sein.
Immer mehr Menschen
unternehmen etwas dagegen.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass wir 30 t Tomaten wegwerfen.
Als wir das öffentlich machten,
stiess das auf grosses Interesse.
Alle waren empört.
Wir konnten die 30 t
wirklich verkaufen.
V.a. Junge
wollen nicht mehr akzeptieren,
dass einwandfreie Lebensmittel
auf den Feldern liegen bleiben
oder wegen kleiner Mängel
nicht in die Läden kommen.
Das kann ja nicht sein!
Irgendwo verhungern sie.
850 Mio. Menschen
haben zu wenig zu essen
und wir werfen es
wegen eines Wurzelansatzes,
den wir sowieso abschneiden, weg.
Da weiss ich gar nicht,
was ich sagen soll.
Warum gibt es in der Schweiz
so viel Foodwaste?
Was läuft falsch?
Und was kann man dagegen tun?
Das erste Foodwaste-Restaurant
in der Schweiz.
Der ehemalige Gault-Millau-Koch
Mirko Buri
verwirklicht hier seinen Lebenstraum.
Heute gibt es einen Kartoffelgratin,
darauf hat es Blumenkohl.
Die Kartoffeln bereite ich jetzt
vor. Es sind Kartoffeln mit Schorf.
Die Kartoffeln
haben keine schöne Oberfläche,
sie haben eben ein wenig Schorf.
Über 61 % der kompletten Kartoffel-
ernte wandert in den Abfall.
Dies, weil sie nicht die gewünschte
Form, die gewünschte Grösse
oder die glatte Oberfläche haben.
Ja.
Und wir sagen eben, dass das
in der verarbeiteten Version
den Leuten keine Rolle spielt.
Und darum ... Jawohl.
... können wir sie eigentlich
sehr gut verarbeiten.
Das sind Knickeier.
Die haben wir von einem Hof,
der hier ganz in der Nähe liegt.
Es lohnt sich fast nicht mehr,
sie zu vermarkten.
Darum brauchen wir sie.
Ein wenig Paniermehl, aus Altbrot
gemacht, das die Äss-Bar verkauft.
Das Altbrot kann man super brauchen,
um damit Blumenkohl
auf polnische Art zu machen,
dazu ein Kartoffelgratin
mit etwas Basilikumsauce.
Als mein Sohn auf die Welt kam
und ich daheim das Kochen
für die Familie übernommen habe,
wurde mir bewusst,
wie viel wir eigentlich wegwerfen.
Darum fand ich, dass ich eigentlich
für andere Leute kochen könne -
und zwar aus Foodwaste.
Buris Frau, seine Mutter
und auch sein Schwager arbeiten mit.
Billiger ist das Essen hier
jedoch nicht.
Im Moment muss ich in Foodwaste
so viel Zeit investieren,
dass es etwa gleich teuer
wie ein konventionelles Menü ist.
Das soll aber auch so sein.
Schlussendlich ist ja
die ganze Arbeit und Wertschöpfung,
die man hineingibt, das,
was das Produkt teuer macht.
Der Bauer soll schliesslich auch
etwas für sein Produkt bekommen.
Und zwar einen fairen Preis,
damit er davon leben kann.
Darum ist es nicht das Ziel,
dass es hier viel günstiger ist
und die Leute kommen,
weil es günstig ist,
sondern weil wir darauf achten,
dass 100 % verarbeitet wird
und auf den Feldern
nicht so viel weggeworfen wird.
Dominik Waser übernimmt
in der Region Zürich Gemüse,
das zu klein oder zu gross ist
für den Handel,
und darum in der Biogasanlage
landen würde.
Das ist Gemüse
von verschiedenen Bauern.
Wir sammeln alles
zweitklassige Gemüse zusammen.
Danach verpacken wir es.
Für 37 Fr. pro Paket
gibt es 6 kg Gemüse.
Von den Gurken kommen zwei bis drei,
von den Randen eine bis zwei, drei,
auch von den Zwiebeln,
je nachdem wie gross sie sind.
Mit Fenchel und Mais
können wir das Paket auffüllen.
Bekannt geworden ist Dominik Waser,
weil er 2018 über Facebook
in kürzester Zeit
30 t überschüssige Tomaten
verkauft hat.
Zuerst waren wir selber überrascht
und damit überfordert,
dass wir in zwei Tagen
30 t Tomaten verkauft haben.
Dann fanden wir, dass wir das nicht
einfach so stehen lassen können.
Jetzt hatten wir den Zugang
und wussten davon.
Wenn man das gesehen hat,
muss man etwas dagegen tun.
Das ist ein Missstand.
Es ist eine Frechheit,
dass wir uns das leisten,
weil wir ein Land sind, das sich
nicht selber ernähren kann.
Wir müssen importieren.
Das, was wir hier produzieren,
geschieht unter teuren Bedingungen.
Dass wir uns den Luxus leisten, mehr
zu importieren, ist eine Frechheit.
Waser hat sein Studium
als Umweltingenieur abgebrochen,
um sich voll auf das Foodwaste-
Engagement zu konzentrieren.
Auch hier
helfen Freunde und Familie mit.
Dieses Bewusstsein
hat er sicher ein wenig von mir,
vielleicht sogar von meinem Vater.
Er war Gärtner und hat schon früh
biologisch angepflanzt.
Er hat sich
auch möglichst gesund ernährt.
Er hat auch gelernt, dass man stur
sein muss, um etwas durchzusetzen.
Das hat er sicher von meinem Vater.
Eine gewisse Konsequenz,
damit man etwas erreicht
und eine Vorreiterrolle hat.
Sonst bewegt man eben nichts.
Das Thema Foodwaste
ist allgegenwärtig:
in der Landwirtschaft,
in der Gastroszene,
aber am meisten Foodwaste,
mehr als 1 Mio. t,
fällt in den Privathaushalten an.
Vanessa Bergant
hat einen zweijährigen Sohn.
Seine Geburt hat ihre Sicht
auf die Dinge verändert.
Irgendwann wird er fragen:
"Warum machst du das so
oder wie machst du das"?"
Ich habe mich für das, was ich
mache, verantwortlicher gefühlt.
Ich fragte mich:
"Finde ich gut, was ich mache"?
"Und wenn nicht,
warum mache ich es dann?"
Seither versucht sie,
nichts mehr wegzuwerfen.
Früher hatte ich ein Menü im Kopf
und ging spezifisch dafür einkaufen.
Jetzt mache ich es umgekehrt.
Jetzt habe ich einfach sozusagen
meine Grundnahrungsmittel.
Dort habe ich Getreide, Mehl,
Hefe und solche Sachen.
Hier unten habe ich Gemüse.
Jetzt kombiniere ich einfach.
Äh, Sachen, die ich ...
... die ich selber mache,
was ich früher nicht machte,
wie z.B. Tomatensauce
oder Bärlauchpesto,
Die habe ich früher
nicht selber gemacht.
Jetzt mache ich sie selber
und sie ist gut.
Das ist das Joghurt meines Mannes.
Es ist sein Lieblingsjoghurt
und darauf will er nicht verzichten.
Ja und dann bleibt das eben so.
Vorher haben wir
alle Resten einfach weggeworfen.
Jetzt werfen wir
praktisch nichts mehr weg.
Das einzige, das wir wegwerfen sind
die Rüstabfälle, also Rüstresten.
Sonst versuchen wir die Resten am
nächsten Tag noch zum Menü zu geben
oder zwischendurch zu essen.
Also vom Essen
werfen wir fast nichts mehr weg.
Das sind gefüllte Peperoni. Gestern
Abend haben wir nicht alle gegessen.
Jetzt gibt es sie zum Mittagessen.
Ihren Abfall
konnte sie so massiv reduzieren.
Das sind Sachen,
die ich wieder zurückbringe.
Sie sind aus einem Mehrwegsystem.
Achtung, Schätzchen! - Mama?
Das ist nun Abfall von ...
Ja, es ist sicher
Abfall von zwei Wochen.
Vorher brauchten wir
zwei 35-l-Säcke pro Woche,
d.h. im Monat 280 l.
Und jetzt haben wir 17 l.
Mirco Buri bespricht
mit seinem Koch die nächsten Menüs.
Auch er wirft nichts weg.
Das spielt keine Rolle.
Ich würde die Gurke machen.
Heute kommt die Lieferung,
da muss das hier alles weg.
Kartoffeln haben wir viel gebraucht.
- Das sind die letzten sauberen.
Schauen wir uns den Plan an!
Ich sehe noch Auberginen und Lauch.
- Ja, das machen wir.
Heute mache ich Bratkartoffel mit
gefüllten Peperoni und Erbsenpüree.
Hier kannst du schreiben:
Gurkensalat und anderer Salat.
Der Produktionsplan
ist sehr wichtig für uns,
damit wir nicht zu viel kochen.
65 % der Abfälle in der Gastronomie
entstehen durch Überproduktion.
Wenn er denkt:
"Uh, es kommen viele Leute,
ich koche lieber für zehn mehr!"
Wir kochen nur,
was wir wirklich brauchen.
Dafür haben wir Zeit zum Rüsten.
Also bis dann ...
Das Restaurant überlässt er heute
seiner Frau Manu.
Für die NGO United Against Waste
fährt er nach Grindelwald,
um Foodwaste zu verhindern.
Dort ist das Hotel Belvedere.
Es macht zusammen mit dem ganzen
Küchenteam ein Teamcoaching.
Ich schaue ihre Abfälle an
und versuche,
sie um 30, 40 % zu reduzieren.
Ich bin mega nervös,
denn ich habe nur 3 Std. Zeit,
um dort etwas zu verändern.
Mirko Buri ist sehr gefragt,
das Restaurant läuft gut,
er berät andere, gibt Kochkurse,
ist auf dem besten Weg,
grösser zu werden.
Aber das ist nicht das, was er will.
Wenn jemand
das grosse Geld machen will,
wenn einer mehr verdienen will,
dann soll er das gerne tun.
Ich bin glücklich
mit meinem Geschäft,
meinem Schwager und mit Manu ...
In dieser Grösse, wir machen
200 bis 300 Essen pro Tag.
Für mich stimmt das so.
Ich denke, ein Mass zu haben
und sagen "Okay, so ist es gut,
hier höre ich auf".
Das war für mich
eine wichtige Erkenntnis.
Man ist oft von aussen gesteuert
und hat das Gefühl, dass man wachsen
und grösser werden muss.
Das zählt in unserer Gesellschaft.
Das ist einer der grossen Fehler
bei unserem Denken.
Er hat seine Prioritäten
anders gesetzt.
Den Abfall ins Sichtbare holen -
ich glaube, das ist sehr ...
Das ist der erste Schritt,
den man machen muss.
Man muss sich bewusst werden,
dass man selber
sehr, sehr viel Abfall produziert.
Viele Leute
sind sich das nicht bewusst.
Jeder versteckt,
verdrängt, vergisst es.
Hast du eine so grosse Waage?
- Nein.
Das ist aber nicht von gestern?
Das ist von gestern.
Das ist nur das Gekochte.
Auch im Hotel Belvedere
muss Mirko Buri zuerst klarmachen,
dass in der Gastronomie
sehr viel Foodwaste entsteht.
Das sind die neuen Zahlen
vom Bundesamt für Umwelt.
2,6 Mio. t werden in der Schweiz
jährlich entsorgt.
Es gibt verschiedene Akteure,
die da mitwirken,
die dafür verantwortlich sind.
In der Gastronomie sind das 11 %.
Das ist sehr hoch.
Das sind 290'000 t.
Wie viele Portionen
könnte ich servieren,
wenn ich 1/2 kg dazugeben würde?
290 Mio. mal zwei?
Wie viele Leute könnten da
zum Nachtessen vorbeikommen? - 580.
580 Mio.
- Dafür braucht man keinen Rechner.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander
und lachen. *
Nur zur Erklärung.
Teller könnt ihr euch vorstellen.
580 Mio. Teller - das ist ...
So viele Einwohner
hat ganz Südamerika.
Buri zeigt auf,
wo der Abfall entsteht.
Da sind tatsächlich nur die Resten.
Rüstabfälle, das Gekochte.
Und das ist auch noch von heute.
Das ist von gestern
und heute Morgen.
Küche: Überproduktion.
Das ist das grösste Problem.
Das zweitgrösste Problem
ist der ständige Tellerrücklauf.
Würdet ihr bestätigen, dass das hier
auch der Fall ist? - Ja.
Es ist nichts abgelaufenes
vom Lager? - Nein.
Er rechnet auch vor,
wie viel das Hotel
mit einer Vollkostenrechnung
konkret sparen könnte.
80 kg mal 24?
Wie viel bekommst du?
Susanne Hauser von der
Besitzerfamilie rechnet und staunt.
Wie haben wir früher gerechnet?
80 mal wie viel hast du gesagt?
- 80 mal 24.
1'920.
- Pro Tag? - Ja.
Im Monat 57'600.
Das sind alle Kosten zusammen,
wenn man die Warenkosten
mal die 24 Fr. rechnen würde.
Das ist erschreckend viel,
wenn man das so sagen kann.
Aber dafür sind Sie ja hier.
Man kann es immer noch verbessern.
Von daher gesehen
wissen wir, was wir zu tun haben.
Dominik Waser
beliefert auch Restaurants.
Die Grundidee ist,
dass wir es schaffen, die Verbindung
zwischen der Landwirtschaft und
den Konsumenten wiederaufzubauen,
weil wir glauben,
dass das der Hauptgrund ist
für unser Foodwaste-Problem.
Wir wissen einfach nicht mehr,
was es braucht,
bis ein Rüebli gewachsen
und im Laden ist.
Wenn wir diese Wertschätzung
nicht wieder gewinnen,
sind wir nicht bereit, etwas gegen
diese Verschwendung zu unternehmen.
Es ist unser Ziel,
das durch Aktionen
und Sensibilisierungsarbeit,
aber auch durch konkrete Projekte,
wie die Lieferung von Gemüse
in Restaurants, lösen können.
Das Cafe Boy in Zürich
kocht nachhaltig und regional.
Bei Küchenchef Roman Wyss
rennt Dominik Waser offene Türen ein.
Ich konnte nicht alles mitnehmen,
der Rest kommt noch.
Randen, Rüebli und Zwiebeln
habe ich hier.
Tipptopp.
So sieht das Gemüse eben aus,
wenn es äh ...
Das ist so.
Ich finde es komisch, dass man
von  zweitklassigem Gemüse spricht.
Ich finde,
es ist geschmacklich besser
als manch konventionelles Gemüse.
In einer Küche hat man Messer
und kann das wegschneiden,
das man nicht gebrauchen kann.
Und ähm ...
Wenn man z.B.
ein solches Rüebli hat,
jetzt finde ich fast keines,
das zum Schälen schwierig ist,
dann macht man damit Bouillon,
wenn man es
nicht gleichmässig schneiden kann.
Von daher ist das Gemüse
schnell aufgebraucht.
Bei der jüngeren Generation,
also z.B. bei meinen zwei Töchtern,
ist das ein Thema.
Ich glaube, im Allgemeinen wird
das Essen wieder mehr zum Thema.
Woher kommen die Lebensmittel?
Weiter wäre da auch die Frage, ob
unsere Bauern davon leben können.
Wäre es nicht besser,
wenn die Bauern den Lohn
von ihren Produkten hätten,
als ihren Lohn
mittels Subventionen zu bekommen,
damit sie überleben können?
Da wäre die Idee von diesem Gemüse
sicher besser.
Vanessa Bergant
kauft zwar keine Zweitklassware,
aber sie geht regelmässig
auf den Markt
und kauft
direkt von den Bauern.
Diese müssen
neue Absatzmärkte finden,
weil sie im Grosshandel immer weniger
für ihre Produkte bekommen.
Welche Äpfel willst du?
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Willst du den Apfel hineintun?
Viele finden die Lebensmittel
auf dem Markt zu teuer.
Dabei geben die Schweizer
im Schnitt nur noch 6,7 %
ihres Lohnes für Lebensmittel aus.
Willst du auch eine Birne?
Zuerst die Äpfel wiegen.
- Vielen Dank.
Mein Partner
hat einen ganz normalen Lohn.
Nicht einen mega guten Lohn.
Auch keinen schlechten, aber ...
Wir kaufen z.B.
nicht sehr viele Kleider
oder bestellen
dieses und jenes online.
Dann liegt das schon drin.
Jetzt habe ich z.B. für die Äpfel
und die Birne 7 Fr. ausgegeben.
Aber das reicht für die ganze Woche.
Das ist eigentlich okay.
Das Gemüse kostete 21 Fr., aber auch
das reicht für die ganze Woche.
Dann finde ich das okay.
Pro Woche 30 Fr.
für Gemüse und Früchte
sollte sich jeder leisten können.
Ich verstehe es, wenn man
einen wirklich schlechten Lohn hat.
Dann liegt das nicht drin.
Aber viele sagen, dass sie sich
das nicht leisten können,
kaufen aber immer wieder neue
Schuhe, neue Jacken, neue Taschen.
Vielleicht haben sie einfach
eine andere Budgetaufteilung.
Vielen Dank.
- Du kannst die Birne nehmen.
Schau, da ist ein Kälbchen!
Baby?
- Ja, das ist ein Baby-Kälbchen.
Dort melkt er.
Molken.
- Melken .
Baby-Kälbchen, Baby-Kälbchen.
In der Landwirtschaft werden jährlich
200'000 t Lebensmittel produziert
und weggeworfen, bevor sie
überhaupt in den Verkauf kommen.
Mirco Buri
sammelt solche Lebensmittel ein.
Insgesamt
betreuen wir 40 Bauernhöfe
und übernehmen
ihre überschüssige Waren.
Wie z.B. die Legehennen, Knickeier,
Lauch, der oben abgeschnitten wird,
Schnittlauch,
der abgeschnitten ist, ähm ...
Der Zwiebelbauer -
ja, es gibt überall Abfälle.
Diese haben wir eigentlich
schon ziemlich sortiert.
Diese fahren wir immer dienstags
auf einer Tour ab.
So holen wir die Überschüsse
von verschiedenen Bauern ab.
Für uns ist es wichtig,
breit abgestützt zu sein
und immer ausweichen zu können,
wenn jemand keinen Überschuss hat.
Dann haben wir einen anderen Bauern,
den wir unterstützen können.
Fast alle Bauern
produzieren Überschüsse,
aber viele haben Angst, auf die
Missstände aufmerksam zu machen.
Pascal Gutknecht
betreibt im Freiburger Seeland
einen grossen Betrieb.
Mirko Buri ist nicht der einzige,
der hier Überschussware bezieht.
Morgen, morgen!
- Guten Morgen, Mirko!
Geht's gut?
- Ja.  - Gut.
Salü.
-  Salü.
Tipptopp. Bist du parat?
- Ja, sicher.
Auch Simon Weidmann,
der die Äss-Bar und den Gemüsegarten
in der Berner Altstadt betreibt,
holt hier regelmässig seine Ware.
Ist das alles B-Qualität?
Ja, das ist alles
zweitklassige Ware.
Sie sind zu gross, zu klein,
falsch abgeschnitten.
Unförmig.
Das kann man alles
nicht im normalen Handel verkaufen.
Das bisherige System
ist sicher suboptimal,
weil es die Klassierung gibt,
zu gross, zu klein.
Aber grundsätzlich
ist ein Rüebli ein Rüebli.
Ein Fenchel ist ein Fenchel,
egal ob so oder so gross.
Das macht keinen Unterschied.
Er ist genau gleich gut,
wenn man ihn in den Salat gibt.
Wir verkaufen ihn,
denn er hat einen Wert.
Jemand hat dafür gearbeitet,
jemand hat ihn geerntet.
Es wurde
auch Energie in ihn gesteckt.
Darum muss er unter das Volk,
muss gegessen werden.
Wir beweisen, dass es funktioniert.
Wir haben jeden Tag Kunden,
die das kaufen.
Damit zeigen sie,
dass sie ihr Geld für etwas
ausgeben, das nicht perfekt ist.
Kaum zu glauben, was hier alles
als Zweitklassware liegen bleibt
und v.a. auch aus welchen Gründen.
Hier hat es einen kleinen Riss.
Vielleicht hat sie sich
beim Wachstum irgendwo angeschlagen.
Wir haben Wachstumsrisse,
die es bei eher älteren,
eher weniger gezüchteten Sorten
geben kann.
Die Ausfärbung,
die durch die Hitzeperiode Mühe hat,
schön homogen rot zu werden.
Das ist alles Ware, die normaler-
weise auf dem Kompost landet.
Bei dieser Tomate
sprechen wir von 3 ...
300 g, die Ressourcen brauchte,
sie brauchte Wasser, Energie,
sie brauchte Manpower.
Jetzt stellt sich die Frage:
"Geht es uns so gut, dass wir sie
einfach in den Abfall werfen?"
Das ist eine grosse Frage.
Der, der nebenan
sein Einfamilienhäuschen besitzt,
kommt zu mir und sagt: "Ich darf im
Sommer meinen Rasen nicht wässern,
weil die Gemeinde
zu wenig Wasser hat."
"Du wässerst dein Land,
damit ein Produkt entsteht,
und am Schluss erntest du es nicht."
Kannst du mir das erklären?
Wir beziehen ja viele Kartoffeln
aus anderen Ländern.
Dort haben sie
kein Problem mit Foodwaste,
weil sie es
auf den lokalen Markt geben können.
Sie schicken die schönsten zu uns,
zum verwöhnten High-end-Segment.
Den Rest nimmt alles ihr Markt.
Und wir haben
mit diesen keine Chance.
Man müsste sie exportieren, weil sie
hier keinen Abnehmer finden.
Weil wir in diesem High-end-Segment
leben, das das nicht zulässt.
Der Kurzlauch
ist heute eine Modeerscheinung.
Früher kannte man den Lauch
lange mit Blättern.
Der Laub- oder Blätterteil
enthält viel Chlorophyll.
Der grüne Anteil hätte eigentlich
auch speziell viele Vitamine.
Heute schneidet man das ab,
weil es nicht so gut
in die Tragetasche passt.
Beim eingekürzten Lauch
gibt es einen Ausfall
von 25-30 % des Gesamtgewichts,
das ja gewachsen ist,
das essfähig wäre.
Das nehmen wir heute gar nicht mehr
nach Hause, das bleibt auf dem Feld.
Erntet man maschinell
grössere Mengen
und geht das Messer in den Boden,
gibt es immer wieder Stellen,
bei denen es den Lauch abschneidet.
Den muss man dann wegwerfen,
den verkauft man nicht,
obwohl die Ware
eigentlich schön ist.
Sie muss von oben bis unten
perfekt sein,
obwohl man sie am Schluss
wieder abrüstet.
Den Boden schneidest du ja auch ab.
Ja, aber jetzt nicht mehr,
denn du hast das ja schon gemacht.
Muss ich jetzt mehr bezahlen,
weil du schon geschnitten hast?
Das zeugt davon,
dass etwas im System nicht stimmt.
Dass man sich das leisten kann,
ist äh ...
Das ist das, wogegen wir kämpfen.
Dass man nicht mehr einfach sagt:
"Hey, das ist Abfall."
Das kann doch nicht sein!
Irgendwo verhungern sie. 850 Mio.
Menschen haben zu wenig zu essen.
Und wir werfen es
wegen eines Wurzelansatzes,
den man sowieso abschneidet, fort.
Da weiss ich nicht mehr,
was ich sagen soll.
Steffen Ris
gehört zur Fenaco-Gruppe.
Diese macht die strengen Vorgaben
im konventionellen Gemüseanbau,
zusammen mit den Branchenverbänden
der Produzenten
und den Detaillisten
wie Migros und Coop.
Die Fenaco-Gruppe ist die markt-
mächtige Drehscheibe im Grosshandel.
Sie macht einerseits
die Anbauplanung für die Bauern,
nimmt
deren Landwirtschaftsprodukte ab,
sortiert diese aus und verkauft
die Ware an die Detaillisten.
Ein Rüebli muss eine gewisse Länge,
Dicke und Grösse haben,
damit es
überhaupt weiterverarbeitet wird.
Von der Fenaco möchte niemand
vor die Kamera treten.
Man verweist an den Verband
der Gemüseproduzenten.
Wir sind darauf angewiesen, dass man
auf uns zukommt und uns sagt,
wenn etwas nicht mehr stimmt.
Wir sind immer bereit, die
Qualitätsnormen zu überprüfen.
Das geschah
vor vier Jahren zum letzten Mal.
Wenn wieder eine entsprechende
Forderung auf uns zukommt,
dann prüfen wir das
selbstverständlich.
In der lebensmittelverarbeitenden
Industrie
gingen 2019 700'000 t
Lebensmittel verloren.
Das hat das Bundesamt für Umwelt
berechnet.
Rüebli wie diese
landen in der Biogasanlage.
Beim Schweizer Bauernverband
ist man mit den strikten Vorgaben,
was das Aussehen
der Landwirtschaftsprodukte betrifft,
nicht einverstanden.
Unsere Botschaft ist klar:
Wir müssen bei den Toleranzen,
was die Qualitätskriterien
anbelangt, grosszügiger werden.
Es macht wirklich keinen Sinn,
wenn man gute Produkte,
die man essen kann, nicht in
der Nahrungsmittelkette verwertet.
Entsprechend müssen die einzelnen
Branchen die Qualitätskriterien
wirklich kritisch hinterfragen,
Anpassungen vornehmen,
wo es nötig ist.
Viele Bauern haben allerdings
Angst vor solchen Anpassungen,
denn der Handel droht
mit unberechenbaren Konsequenzen.
Es wird gesagt, wenn
Qualitätskriterien gelockert werden,
kauft der Konsument
weniger von diesem Produkt,
also der Markt geht zurück.
Auf der anderen Seite
wird auch gesagt:
"Wenn die Qualität
der Schweizer Produkte gesenkt wird
und die Importprodukte
die höhere Qualität haben,
dann schwenken die Konsumenten
auf Importprodukte um."
Ich glaube,
darum ist es auch wichtig,
dass die ganze Wertschöpfungskette
das zusammen macht -
die Verarbeiter, der Detailhandel,
aber auch die Konsumenten.
Ich glaube,
nur so kommen wir zum Ziel.
Es gibt aber auch Betriebe,
die sich dem Diktat der Grosshändler
entziehen.
Der Gutsbetrieb Rheinau
gehört dazu.
Hier wird nachhaltig produziert
und noch von Hand gejätet.
David Jacobsen
ist einer der Geschäftsführer.
Nur einmal hat er bisher versucht,
mit den grossen Händlern
ins Geschäft zu kommen.
Im Zusammenhang mit der Umstellung
von Coop auf Demeter
fanden wir, dass wir als grösster
Demeter-Betrieb in der Schweiz
auch mitmachen wollen.
Wir hofften, dass wir das
positiv beeinflussen können.
Rückblickend war das etwas naiv.
Aber wir haben mitgemacht.
Wir bauten Artischocken, Schalotten,
Kürbisse und gelbe Zucchetti an.
Es war so,
dass wir ein wenig gelbe Zucchetti
und ein wenig Artischocken
anlieferten.
Dann fielen die Preise
in den Keller.
Wir sagten von Anfang an,
was unsere Preise seien.
Dann teilte ich ihnen mit,
dass ich zu diesen Preisen
nicht mehr liefern würde.
Sie sollen mich wieder anrufen,
wenn sie einen anständigen Preis
bezahlen würden.
Ich habe nie mehr
etwas von ihnen gehört.
Der Handel mit Bioprodukten
funktioniert gleich,
aber über andere Plattformen.
David Jacosben ist überzeugt,
dass dieses System
die unbefriedigende Situation
mit ausgelöst hat
und den Bauern schadet.
Das grosse Problem ist,
dass man die Pflicht hat,
in den Grossverteilern
die Regale zu füllen.
D.h., die Plattformen haben zwar das
Recht, einzelne Produkte zu liefern,
und sie haben
meistens das Alleinrecht.
Sie müssen die Produkte
aber liefern können.
Und wenn sie nicht liefern können,
müssen sie eine Busse bezahlen.
Um die Busse zu umgehen,
bauen sie viel zu viel an.
Das funktioniert vielleicht
einmal in einem von zehn Jahren.
Sonst hat es immer zu viel.
Das zu viel
muss irgendwo abgewälzt werden.
Das wird dann eben
auf den Bauer abgewälzt
und kommt als Ausschuss
in die Biogasanlage.
Davon sieht der Bauer
keinen Rappen mehr.
Gleichzeitig bekommt er für den Rest
auch noch einen schlechteren Preis,
da die Marktlage gesättigt ist.
Dort sehe ich das Problem.
Die Rheinau macht
bei dieser Überproduktion nicht mit
und hat sich
auf den Direktverkauf an Marktfahrer,
Läden und Restaurants konzentriert.
Zudem nimmt man hier in Kauf, dass
nicht alles jederzeit verfügbar ist.
Betriebe wie die Rheinau
sind die Ausnahme,
die meisten Bauern arbeiten,
wie Pascal Gutknecht,
mit den Plattformen der Grosshändler
zusammen.
Ah, das ist nun meines?
Sie machen auch
die Anbauplanung mit ihnen.
Die kommen
aus diesem Streifen heraus.
Aus diesem Abschnitt
gab es diese Rüebli.
Sehr viele.
- Und da sind aber auch ...
... solche drin.
Wir sind in der Ernte zu spät dran.
Es hat bereits geplatzte Rüebli,
die müssen wir aussortieren.
Das wird alles Ausschuss sein.
Es ist nicht so einfach,
eine Jahresplanung
auf den Tag genau zu erstellen.
Die Natur hat natürlich
auch ihre Fehldaten drin.
Ein solches Rüeblifeld kann plötz-
lich zwei Wochen früher bereit sein.
Wenn aber plötzlich
drei Wochen lang die Bise weht
und schlechtes Wetter herrscht,
kann ein Salatfeld
drei Wochen später bereit sein.
Eine Punktplanung zu machen,
ist also sehr schwierig.
Da werfe ich
auch niemandem etwas vor:
"Du hättest die
schon nehmen sollen."
Es ist so schwierig, das zu planen.
Da braucht es eine gewisse Toleranz
des Produzenten zum Kunden.
Das ist eben ein Teil des Spiels.
Doch immer häufiger bringen Bauern
ihre Ware gar nicht mehr los,
eine Abnahmegarantie
haben sie nämlich nicht.
Wichtig ist, dass man sich
an die Abmachungen hält.
Eine Woche früher oder später,
ist nicht entscheidend.
Aber wenn der Kunde sagt:
"Ich nehme die Rüebli nicht mehr,
weil ich sie in Spanien
billiger gefunden habe."
Dann sitze ich hier
auf 100 t Rüebli.
Wenn man dort steht
und die vielen Abfälle sieht,
würde das jedem so gehen.
Es zerreisst einem das Herz,
wenn man sieht, wie viel produziert,
und dann fortgeworfen wird.
Am besten wäre es,
langfristig etwas zu bewirken,
dass der Produzent einen Weg hat,
diese Lebensmittel zu verkaufen.
Die Detaillisten
übernehmen diese Ware nicht.
Sie können auswählen
und nehmen nur das Beste -
alles schön normiert.
Coop lehnt ein Interview ab.
Bei Migros weiss man
um den Zwiespalt und gibt Auskunft.
Das Auge ist nicht nur mit,
sondern das Auge kauft auch mit.
Wir sehen und spüren das,
wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass unsere Kunden sehr darauf
achten, dass ein Produkt,
wie z.B. diese Rüebli,
schön aussehen.
Wenn man versuchen möchte,
das wieder mehr in das Bewusstsein
der Leute zu bringen,
mehr Sensibilisierung
bei unseren Kunden anzuregen,
dann müssten alle
am gleichen Strang ziehen.
Man müsste ein Ziel definieren,
auf das alle in der Branche
hinarbeiten.
Alle zusammen, das sind die Verbände,
die Grossisten und die Detaillisten.
Wäre Migros denn bereit, die strengen
optischen Bestimmungen zu lockern?
Das ist momentan ein Thema.
Man muss es wieder aufgreifen.
Wie sind momentan die Normen?
Sind sie zu streng?
Müsste man sie lockern?
Das müsste sicher
in kleinen Schritten stattfinden.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass bei den Kunden
mittlerweile
ein Grundbewusstsein da ist:
"Was passiert mit den Produkten,
wenn sie nicht mehr
verkauft werden können?"
Wenn auch von dieser Seite
ein Entgegenkommen kommt,
wenn alle gemeinsam etwas machen,
dann könnte es
in die richtige Richtung gehen.
Um Foodwaste im Laden zu verhindern,
steigt Migros nun landesweit bei
der Foodwaste-App Too Good To Go ein.
Was nicht mehr
so gut aussieht im Gestell,
wird jeden Tag aussortiert
und kurz vor Ladenschluss
als Überraschungspaket zu einem
Drittel des Preises abgegeben.
Da ist einiges zusammengekommen.
- Ja.
Was ist z.B. das Problem
dieser Peperoni?
Hier z.B. ist sie weich.
Die können wir nicht top verkaufen.
Anstatt sie wegzuwerfen,
können wir sie
in diesen Kisten sammeln.
Es hat schon weiche Stellen.
- Genau.
Migros gibt schon bisher
einen Teil der Ausschussware
an Organisationen wie Tischlein
deck dich oder Schweizer Tafel ab.
Es gibt einen Unterschied
zwischen Produkten,
die wir für Too Good To Go abgeben
oder Produkte, die wir
karikativen Organisationen abgeben.
Dort geben wir v.a. auch Konserven,
also Produkte,
die noch etwas länger halten.
Bei Too Good To Go
geht es um die Sachen,
die unmittelbar
oder sehr bald ablaufen,
damit man sie
schneller unter die Leute bringt.
Mit der App
kann man die Portionen reservieren
und kurz vor Ladenschluss abholen.
Das wäre für Sie.
Einen schönen Abend.
- Adieu, danke.
Die Kunden, die kommen,
kommen regelmässig.
Manchmal komme ich
zweimal pro Woche.
Einmal kaufe ich Früchte und Gemüse
im Supermarkt ein.
Dort ist es
natürlich auch sehr billig.
Dort bekommt man
viele Sachen günstiger.
Mittlerweile machen
2'000 Restaurants und Läden mit.
Migros alleine kann so pro Jahr
1 Mio. Portionen Gemüse und Früchte
billiger weitergeben,
die sonst im Abfall landen würden.
Auch die Nachfrage nach Läden,
die ausschliesslich Zweitklassware
verkaufen, steigt.
Die Äss-Bar und der Gemüsegarten
in der Berner Altstadt beweisen das.
Simon Weidmann
hat vor zwei Jahren angefangen.
Das Gemüse, das er
bei Pascal Gutknecht geholt hat,
verkauft sich gut.
Bei uns sind Sachen tendenziell
etwas günstiger als im Detailhandel.
Das ist so, weil wir es auch
etwas günstiger beziehen können.
Das geben wir dem Kunden weiter.
Aber es ist ein hartes Pflaster,
die Margen sind klein.
Reich werden wir damit sicher nicht.
Aber das werden
auch die Landwirte nicht.
Wir können aber die Kosten decken,
die wir haben.
Wir glauben eben schon,
dass wir etwas machen können.
Wir können etwas bewegen.
Wir können in den Menschen
etwas pflanzen, das wachsen kann.
So verändern wir die Welt.
Der Mitgründer der Äss-Bar
gleich nebenan ist optimistisch.
Bei der Äss-Bar war es ähnlich.
Hier bekommt man seit vier Jahren
Backwaren einen Tag später
zum halben Preis.
Das Coole ist,
dass immer mehr Bäcker mitmachen.
Anfangs war es ziemlich zäh.
Wir mussten hinfahren,
anrufen und fast darum betteln.
Jetzt ist es aber cool.
Man kennt nun
das Konzept der Äss-Bar.
Z.T. rufen die Bäcker auch uns an
und fragen, ob sie mitmachen können,
denn sie hätten Produkte,
die sie nicht verkaufen könnten.
Der gelernte Geograph ist überzeugt,
dass es beim Gemüsegarten
ähnlich laufen wird.
Es hat sicher damit zu tun, dass
kleinere und mittlere Produzenten
sagen: "Ich habe genug von dieser
Friss-oder-stirb-Mentalität,
die im Handel herrscht."
Die sollen mir in die Schuhe blasen,
ich vermarkte das selber.
Mirko Buri
hat 1'500 kg Zweitklassgemüse
für seine Strassenaktion Foodfactory
zusammengekauft.
Eine neue Idee, ein Start-up, das er
vor drei Jahren gegründet hat.
Dafür trommelt er regelmässig
auf Dorfmärkten Freiwillige zusammen,
die ihm beim Rüsten helfen.
So, wunderbar!
In Worb hat er sein Zelt gleich
neben einem Altersheim aufgeschlagen.
Hergestellt wird
eine Bouillonpaste aus Foodwaste,
die sich in Läden verkaufen lässt.
Jeder, der heute Nachmittag
auf den Markt kommt,
sieht, dass hier
etwas gegen Foodwaste gemacht wird.
Sie können 1 Std. ihrer Arbeitszeit
gegen das Problem investieren.
Wir stellen die Infrastruktur,
das Konzept und das Produkt.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Alt und Jung an einem Tisch
nehmen sich diesem Thema an
und helfen, das zu verarbeiten.
Diese Rüebli sind von Pascal.
Pascal bauert im Seeland.
Gestern sagte er uns,
20 t solcher Rüebli seien Ausschuss,
die danach wieder in den Boden
oder den Kompost kommen.
Das ist schade.
- Genau.
Was wir an Gewinn machen,
wird gespendet.
Letztes Jahr z.B. konnten wir damit
beim Foodwastebankett,
das immer auf dem
Berner Bahnhofsplatz stattfindet,
die kompletten Lebensmittelkosten
übernehmen
und den Bauern für die Lebensmittel
einen fairen Preis bezahlen.
Damit helfen alle Leute,
die hier gratis arbeiten, mit,
das Problem zu bekämpfen.
Gleichzeitig
stellen wir ein Produkt her.
Mittlerweile hat Buri
eine grosse Facebook-Community.
Die sind aus dem Welschland.
- Daher hast du die importiert.
Irgendwo gesehen.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung mehr wo.
Auf Facebook.
Ich kenne Mirko schon seit Jahren.
Wir kommen wieder.
Irene, du musst jetzt arbeiten!
Seine Familie
trägt auch diese Aktionen voll mit.
Ohne Manu, seine Frau,
die alles ein bisschen austariert,
wäre Buri allerdings
ziemlich aufgeschmissen.
Wenn ich sie nicht hätte ...
Weil ich so viel Energie habe,
braucht man jemanden,
der einen etwas hinunterholt,
der etwas bremst,
auch entschleunigt.
Der auch einmal sagt:
"So ist es okay:"
"Man muss die Welt
nicht morgen verändern."
Ich bin auch oft
ein sehr nervöser Mensch.
Und jetzt haben wir nicht nur einen,
jetzt haben wir noch einen zweiten,
der gerade so gerne redet
wie der hier. Nicht wahr?
Papi, schau mal!
- Was hast du hier?
Vanessa Bergant
wird von ihrer Familie
ebenfalls unterstützt.
Zusammen mit ihrer Mutter entwickelt
die ausgebildete Naturheilpraktikerin
eine neue Körperpflegelinie.
Ah, jetzt riecht es.
Ohne Verpackung und ausschliesslich
mit natürlichen Zutaten.
Bei ihrem Mann Armin braucht es
etwas mehr Überzeugungskraft.
Er konnte Vanessas
Zerowaste-Bemühungen
am Anfang nicht so viel abgewinnen.
Ich komme
aus einer südländischen Familie.
Meine Mutter stammt aus Marokko,
mein Vater aus Italien.
Die Küche spielt dort
eine sehr grosse Rolle.
Wir sind
nicht unbedingt bekannt dafür,
dass wir sehr Zero-Waste kochen,
mit wenig Fett
und weiss ich nicht was.
Dort hört es bei mir auf.
Wenn Zero-Waste irgendwann
in deinem Teller stattfindet ...
Ich finde, es darf ruhig
etwas deftiger sein, etwas ...
Ich weiss nicht.
- Mehr Fleisch?
Ja, ab und zu etwas mehr Fleisch.
Auch etwas anderes
stört ihn nach wie vor:
Der Aspekt,
der ein paar Reibungspunkte gibt,
ist die Kostenfrage.
Ich glaube, wir geben viel Geld aus
für ein gesundes Leben.
Das finde ich schade, aber ich habe
das Gefühl, das ist ein Fakt.
Es ist schade, dass es so ist.
Wir haben ja nicht die Wahl,
uns gesund und günstig zu ernähren.
Man kann sich
ungesund und günstig ernähren.
Aber nicht umgekehrt.
Das finde ich etwas schade.
Vanessa Bergant
muss noch in den Bioladen.
Ihr Ziel ist, Armin endlich
von Jogurt im Glas zu überzeugen.
Armin, was willst du für ein Jogurt?
Eines mit Schokostreusel.
Es hat mit Schokolade,
mit Aprikosen, Waldbeeren.
Hat es nur so grosse im Glas?
Eigentlich haben sie schon kleine,
aber jetzt sind sie schon weg.
Schokolade.
Nimmst du Schokolade? - Ja.
Oder dieses hier.
Waldbeeren?
- Genau.
Hast du gerne Aprikosen?
Nicht so.
Nature und dieses.
Also Nature,
Himbeere oder Erdbeeren?
Himbeere.
- Himbeere.
Tipptopp.
Joghurt.
Regarde le voiture.
Super!
Das ist
sein Highlight beim Einkaufen.
Traktor.
- Ja, Traktor.
Oh!
Dominik Waser hat in Zürich
eine neue Foodwaste-Aktion gestartet.
Gerade verkauft er
1,7 t Ananas aus Afrika.
Auf Facebook
konnte man sich anmelden.
Verkaufsaktionen
gibt es in Zürich, Basel und Bern.
Die Ananas sind aus Togo.
Sie wurden
von Kleinbauern produziert.
Sie wären eigentlich
in den Grosshandel gekommen.
Der Markt bricht momentan etwas
zusammen oder ist zusammengebrochen.
Die Preise sind am Boden.
Darum sind grössere Abnehmer
abgesprungen.
Und darum haben wir sie
eben doch importiert,
weil sonst die Existenz
von Hunderten Kleinbauern in Togo
gefährdet wäre.
Darum verkaufen wir sie hier
und versuchen, alle wegzubekommen.
Verkauft ihr gut?
Ja, wir schafften es,
ca. 1,5 t an die Leute zu bringen.
Das ist recht viel.
Von den 35 Fr.,
die er für 1 kg Ananas verlangt,
gehen 12 Fr. direkt an die Bauern.
Ein schönes Wochenende!
Auch sein Zweitklass-Gemüse
findet guten Absatz.
Dominik Waser versucht nun,
eine Bewilligung zu bekommen,
um es hier
direkt verkaufen zu können.
Das Ziel ist nicht, dass wir die
Aktionen wöchentlich machen müssen,
auch wenn wir das könnten, denn
jederzeit gibt es irgendein Produkt.
Es gibt viele Produkte, die wir
als Aktion verkaufen könnten.
Aber das Ziel ist,
zu sensibilisieren
und darauf aufmerksam zu machen.
Damit wir den Handel, die Produktion
mit der Zeit so verändern können,
damit das nicht mehr passiert.
Okay, danke.
- Danke dir. Einen schönen Tag.
Sein Gemüse bezieht Waser
u.a. auch auf dem Demeterhof Rheinau
bei David Jacobsen.
Dieser findet es zwar gut,
dass Dominik dafür kämpft,
dass die Konsumenten
wieder direkt vom Hof kaufen.
Aber dass er
mit seinen Foodwaste-Aktionen
Zweitklassgemüse der Plattformen
verkauft,
damit ist er nicht einverstanden.
Wenn man das abnimmt, dann belohnt
man quasi denen ihre Fehlplanung.
Gleichzeitig gibt es Klein-
produzenten, andere Produzenten,
oder Leute, die versuchen,
es anders zu machen,
die 30 t weniger verkaufen.
Die Schweizer essen
eine gewisse Menge an Gemüse.
Sie essen nun nicht plötzlich mehr,
weil Grassrooted
30 t Tomaten rettet.
Die werden dafür an einem anderen
Ort quasi nicht gerettet.
Aber dass man weiss,
dass es das gibt ...
Von daher gesehen ist das gut.
Das ist ein erster Schritt.
Das ist genau der Punkt,
dass es ...
Die Überschüsse oder der Foodwaste
ist das, was man sieht
und das man
an die Medien bringen kann.
Und äh ...
Ja, einen riesigen Aufruhr macht.
Aber das Problem ist eben
viel grösser und viel tiefer.
Ich sehe schon auch, dass es
ein systemisches Problem ist.
Andererseits weist man die Schuld
dafür immer jemandem anderen zu.
Und sehr oft setzt man sich
nicht zusammen an einen Tisch
und sucht nach Lösungen.
Dass sich die Leute
zusammen an einen Tisch setzen
und sensibilisiert werden, das ist
auch das Ziel des Foodwaste-Banketts
auf dem Berner Bahnhofplatz.
Du musst es schräg hineingiessen,
so tropft es immer auf das Blech.
Wo ist der Chef mit dem Lappen?
Der ging nach Hause.
Wir machen nur je zwei. Sie würden
diesen Job schnell übernehmen,
und alle restlichen machen,
dann verteilen wir sie.
Mirko Buri kocht in der Küche
des Hotels Schweizerhof
ein Gratismenu für 1'500 Personen.
Als Hauptspeise gibt es
Gemüsebolognese mit Ofenkartoffeln.
Mh, mh!
Mamma mia!
Schon wieder. Schon wieder.
Jetzt zählt jede Minute.
Wenn ich zu spät fertig bin,
d.h. jede halbe Stunde
kostet mich 200-300 Menüs.
Weil, zwischen ...
... 17.30 und 21 Uhr
ist mein Zeitfenster
in dem die Leute Hunger haben.
Ab 21 Uhr isst niemand mehr.
Wenn ich also zu spät fertig bin,
habe ich 500 Menü übrig.
Darum müssen wir nun Gas geben.
Nun müssen wir noch die Treppe hoch.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich ...
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Gut, danke vielmals!
Wenn man sieht,
wie viele Leute kommen,
wie viele 1 Std. lang anstehen,
um nur einen Teller Essen
zu bekommen ...
Das ist ein Statement,
ein Statement: "Wir machen mit."
Das gibt uns Kraft, das weiter-
zumachen, was wir tagtäglich tun.
Aber Mirko Buri ist noch lange nicht
am Ziel seiner Träume.
Es ist Bern, es ist nicht die Welt,
es ist nicht die Schweiz.
Ich will noch mehr.
Es ist riesig, es ist eines
der schönsten, grössten
Foodwaste-Event das es gibt.
Aber ich will wirklich
etwas Grösseres bewegen können.
Ich möchte auf das Feld gehen
und da soll es heissen:
"Sorry, wir haben nichts."
Ich möchte einmal
im Schweizerhof kochen
und sie sollen mir dann sagen,
was sie alles verändert haben.
Ich möchte das noch mehr spüren.
Ich möchte eine Veränderung sehen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Liz Lei 2020